the head coach of the Cleveland Browns
here on the Rich Eisen show the first
guest who I could ever say a welcome and
I haven't seen you I don't think since
Sports Emmy night a couple of years ago
in New York City but Mike Pettine you
are on the program thanks for joining me
oh thanks for having me you bet so coach
three and two right now how is
everything from your chair as the head
coach of the three and two Browns well
you know the in me what have you done
lately world in the NFL things are good
in my chair right now yes people ask me
on Monday how you doing and my usual
response is I think you already know the
answer since it's a very very much a
black-and-white business that that we're
in so it's it's uh it's been great I'm
very very fortunate here to have been
able to hire an outstanding coaching
staff and work with the GM like ray
farmer and put this team together that
you know have really bought into what
we're what we're trying to get
accomplished and fortunately for us
we've gotten results on the field how do
you is the first time head coach laid
down what what you want to have
accomplished how does one do that as a
head coach in the NFL walking into a
situation like you did well I I think
it's something where you can't be afraid
to delegate I think that the natural
tendency at times is to is to try to
micromanage it all and just I've been
very fortunate here that the the pieces
were really all in place in all the
support staff areas whether it was
equipment training room to the personnel
department that it was really right from
the beginning was all hey what can we
take off of your plate so you guys as a
coaching staff can concentrate just on
football that was huge for us we were
able to come in and and outline what we
were looking for in in players at
certain positions in all three phases
and we were able to get a good part of
the roster the way we wanted it and like
I said that the guys that are here have
bought in and and we're getting some
results and I imagine it was good to
actually get a lead on somebody instead
of the other way around as you've had
happened a couple of times
this year I mean that the the amount of
comebacks you've attempted and some work
and some not have have sort of been off
the charts coach and they think about
yeah my uh my parents were both very
thankful that they didn't have the
cardiac stress that that that we put
them through and some of the other games
and we joke with the players earlier in
the week about hey there's there's no
rule against winning you know via a
couple scores but it was that was a
complete win for us it was nice to go
out and you know we didn't get out of
gate great you know the first quarter we
were I think we were down three nothing
and then it just really kicked in from
there on and played played probably
three three consecutive quarters of the
best football that we've played so far
this year well you mentioned your
parents you're now three hundred and
twenty three career head coach and wins
behind your dad one of the more
legendary high school coaches in the
entire country how much of you leaned on
the coach from Central Bucks West High
School leaned on him a lot and it's it's
a very unique situation here that
there's actually three coaches on our
staff that plateform Chuck ders backs
our linebackers coach played for him in
the 70s I played for him in the 80s and
Jim O'Neill defensive coordinator played
for him in the 90s so he's figured out
everybody's email address so I think he
learned early on that that that if I
didn't pay heed to his email that he he
knows email addresses and he knows what
CC means so those guys a lot of the
emails that were meant for me as well
that is funny
Mike Pettine senior were referring to
but in terms of the type of coach that
you are who is within you a other than
your dad let's put it that way well I
mean it's a combination I mean I've
worked for some some outstanding coaches
throughout my career I played for George
Welsh Virginia I got a chance to be a
graduate assistant for Johnny majors I
was when I walked in the door and in
Baltimore
obviously Brian Billick was the head
coach but Mike Nolan was there Mike
Smith was there Rex was there just that
whole group of coaches that I was able
to work with over time I worked with
with
Pagano as well and then to go to a you
know be there for John Harbaugh's first
year and to learn from him and then end
up in New York obviously with Rex and
then then going to Buffalo to to to gain
some some real valuable experience from
Doug Marrone I mean I said I've been
very fortunate to us to have been able
to work with some some outstanding
coaches and now you enter a weak coach
where you're expected to win you now
have that label certainly with what
you've been able to do through the first
five games and you're visiting a team
that has zero wins this week how do you
approach that task well it's it's uh
it's a challenge that we want to have we
welcome that that early in the season
that when not a lot was expected from us
and and that was that's a particular set
of circumstances you have to deal with
and we always talked about dealing with
adversity and in dealing with the the
the voices outside of the building and
and the negativity and people kind of
wanting to compartmentalize us and cast
us a certain way that we didn't want to
live up to that and now now the
situation has flipped and and it's a
it's one that we're gonna have to handle
I mean it's handling and handling
prosperity is is just as important as
handling adversity so that's really been
the theme of our meetings after every
win that we've had just talked about the
overreaction that is accompanied with
every NFL game you either overreact
every when you're overreacting loss and
given how starved this city has been
this fan base has been for success here
that that that they're very excited and
for and for good reason and we
understand that but at the same time
that we know that we're going down there
to play a very very dangerous opponent
that has a lot of talent that just
hasn't been able to put it together but
that it's a game that will hear trap
game all week but it's important for our
guys to go down there with with the
right mindset and go out and play when
was the last it why isn't Johnny Manziel
your starter question you've you've done
a bit it's been a while okay well it's
been probably since just before the
opener okay just before the opener and
obviously Brian Hoyer has a lot to say
what about that with his play tell me
something about him and what may
him tick that's allowed him to be
successful in the manner that he has
been I just think it's his mentality the
approach he takes towards the game I
mean he is he is a gym rat and he spent
all that time in New England with Tom
Brady and he learned how to prepare for
an opponent and how to how to go out and
you know sink your teeth into a game
plan and what an executor he learned he
learned that from from the from the best
in the business so it's it certainly
shows up in in his play and I think
that's his steadiness has has been key
for us that he's very even keel he
doesn't get too excited when things
aren't going well or things are going
well and he doesn't get too down and
when when things aren't going well and
it's I think that's one of the reasons
why we were able to overcome those two
big deficits once an one in the opener
and then again it against Tennessee I
think he's very much a calming influence
for our guys he's seen a lot of
different looks and knows how to handle
them and that I think that the players
the guys in the huddle they're gonna
reflect her leadership and he's done an
outstanding job Liana and on Sunday
Night Football we saw you know Victor
Cruz go down and we saw the anguish and
how the players rallied around him from
both teams you lost your Center Alex
Mack a guy who had never missed a snap
in his entire career you've lost him to
a leg injury for the season coach so
what what has it been like for you to
sort of throw your arm around to him and
and have the team move forward without
it's such an important piece of your
offensive line and team no it's it's uh
it'll be a big thing for us to have to
overcome I can't understate that and we
also lost our money Brian knew people
would consider to be our best pass
rusher and that's those are both bitter
pills to swallow there but at the same
time I told the team that we would check
the mail but we weren't expecting any
sympathy cuz I mean that's the way the
NFL is that there's no there's no
excuses injuries are a part of it and
good teams are the ones that can adapt
and overcome and and truly test the the
you know the cliche next man up I
thought we did an outstanding job of it
in the game John Greco
slid over from from guard at the center
Palma Kristen came in and got us through
the game at guard and and that's tough
because that's a that's a two-man switch
instead of a straight one for one switch
that's difficult as it is to begin with
but I thought both those guys stepped up
and played well but but moving forward
it's it's going to be a big challenge
for us I mean there you don't just
replace a pro ball Center I mean you
understand that there's potentially
could be some drop-off but but we know
that we have the right guys in the room
to to get it done and be effective coach
I appreciate the time for calling in
have you met LeBron yet have you met him
yet
I have he came out to practice during
training camp okay my my daughter was
working camp as well she's she's 20 I
was she could care less about me she
just wanted a picture with with LeBron
so I know that were I think I got a few
votes for father of the year that day
when I when I got her set up with a
picture with him and then courtside
seats now that's the father of your
stuff no pressure but when you're three
and two this is when you get the asking
I'm telling you how to do your job here
is father of the year but I think right
now this would be good for you okay
that's funny no we're just looking to
get to four into it and then we can
start thinking about that okay coach
thanks again I appreciate you calling in
rich great thanks for having me you bet
that's Mike Patton the head coach of the
three and two Cleveland Browns the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience